[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Renu right Chaudhary she comes to
Yale from the Indian Institute of
Technology in Gua Hadi where she is
assistant professor of humanities and
Social Sciences she is a historian of
photography and art with interest in
South Asian Studies post-colonial theory
popular visual culture and intellectual
history of art today we'll talk with
Professor Roy Chaudhary about her paper
photographs of people monument for a
city welcome Renu thank you so much for
leaving for having me here today
so let's begin with an overview of your
paper tell us about it the paper is on
our intertwined history of visual
conventions political commitment and
intellectual orientation visa vie
arguably the longest-running photo
documentary project on the city of
Calcutta titled people of Calcutta
it the project began in 1977 and ran
through early 1991 and it was done in
two phases the first part of the project
was called Shaheed Minar and it's
translated as monument of martyrs and
the second phase was Cora by Ray it can
be translated as the home in the world
and these two parts under the larger
rubric of people of Calcutta was done
under the umbrella of a Jesuit
organization called Chitra Bonnie and
the word cheater bonnie is a Bangla
world of which you can translate as
words and images but you also can
translate in other ways and also it was
a word that was used by the Nobel
laureate piccoli poet Rabindranath
Tagore to talk about cinema so that
would also have been part of why this
institution was named Shivani
and so the institution was an offshoot
or the sense saviors College in Calcutta
and the Jesuits are like long history in
the city and they had like long
investments both in time and in terms of
time as well as in terms of the breadth
of it in education and social projects
so so this was just an offer yet another
offshoot but the interesting most
interesting part is this is the world we
are talking after the Vatican Second
Council which looks like the early 1960s
and what happened in the vatican ii
council is the catholic church started
incorporating non-christians within the
larger food of the Christian preaching
also it started to deal with what was
then the new media which is now the old
media okay
so how do you incorporate the
non-christians and also how to
incorporate new media in the charts
activities so and with that kind of an
orientation the Catholic Church had the
Canadian pressed of Belgian origin
father Gaston rubbish who moved to
Calcutta in the 60s
sent to UCLA for a degree in film and
media so he got his degree he goes back
to Calcutta and starts this organization
in 1979 teen 70s okay so and followed by
that there were cities of national
emergencies in India and that as you
know as a suspension of democratic
rights of the citizen and there was ban
on photography and more generally media
activities so the organization had to
stall their program of launching this
documentary project which they then had
to wait till 1977 for the emergency to
go over and so that they could start go
out in the public and photograph stuff
that wasn't possible under the emergency
okay
so initially they had a plan of making
audio-visual documentaries but it's also
a time when the the government of india
had at 22,000 input duty on films
ducks so they could not like afford to
get a lot of film so and they've started
with cut films from local film industry
and also depended on donation from other
sources for celluloid films that they
can use so eventually crunchin resources
forced them to move in to steal
photographs and that's how the whole
project began now the reason for
creating this huge body of photographs
and you'll be surprised to know the
number a total of 12,000 photographs
Wow I was yes I asked you yes 12,000
that is a lot that's the total Oubre
of [ __ ] Ronnie collection but for if you
focus only on people of Calcutta project
it's 4,000 okay still it's not less if
you're dealing with 4,000 photographs
that means negatives friends and also
they had index cards and they have
everything catalog so you're basically
dealing with a lot of information and
managing that information so that the
posterity can access that information
forty years down the line and I was a
person who accessed and so yeah so going
back to why this project was launched
and like there was a theological aspect
of it so theology of communication was a
major impetus in conceiving this project
following from the ashley of adding in
second council it also was a foster by a
social commitment to giving face to the
faceless and that was sort of our
tagline for the entire project in two
periods and I'll come to the right
because I do I want you to describe some
of the photographs and who these people
are absolutely I'll come to that so when
you say face to the face list what kind
of people are you thinking about it's
really the everyday lives of very
ordinary citizens of Calcutta who
otherwise would not have photographs
made like so the first part was
specially focused on economical emergen
alized section of Calcutta okay and the
second part was more sort of a
middle-class spend but when the focus
turned their camera to the middle class
it's not the the high achieving middle
class that they were thinking about they
were
more sort of like everyday people in the
city and there everyday very banal
mundane lives and a lot of acts of
everyday living that we won't photograph
even in today's date of Instagram and
camera phone there are certain acts we
think it's just too banal to be
photographed right you need an event to
capture it through a camera so yeah so
there are two segments the first part is
underprivileged Kalkadoon and the second
part is the Madras Calcutta so and the
face for the faceless is more sort of
the for the first section but I also
feel that's the same thought can be
extended to thinking about the muffler's
and as I said I mean we are talking
about a pre-digital era where even the
middle class not all of them would have
a camera for to themselves to document
their save like doing laundry as as
simple as that but it's a very important
ritual of daily living so they would not
have the instrument to record that daily
living and so that was the kind of phase
that the kora by a segment of people of
Calcutta gave an opportunity to people
to have an image of so which wasn't
possible before so and so that that was
one goal the second goal was to counter
the contemporary international as well
as national understanding of Calcutta as
a post-colonial dystopia so so they were
they were thinking Calcutta as a
cityscape
as a space as peoples lived experience
not simply in terms of city of palaces
or worst of urban disasters so those are
the two polarizing world they were
coming like intervening somewhere in the
middle and trying to say that well sure
I mean the world is not perfect there
are problems yeah there are sure
dystopic moments but that does not
necessarily make people hopeless it also
kind of a moment to reflect on the
resilience of the people who live in the
city and fight back a lot of societal as
well as urban injustice and so when
you're thinking about the urban poor
it's not some
the poor as as the wretched as somebody
who we should look down upon it's it's
also the photographs were also meant to
restore humanity and dignity to the
people so for them making a photograph
of the people so an intended city that's
what they call to photograph an
unintended city is to restore humanity
and restore dignity to these people so
that was a major impetus and when
they're looking at the middle class it
was an interesting moment because most
of the photographers and I should have
mentioned before majority of the
photographers were not Catholics okay
and and pretty much all of them aligned
themselves with some sort of leftist
activism okay there were few people who
were Kara card-carrying members of the
Communist Party of India but most were
not card-carrying yet save would avoid
the CPI M in the elections so they had a
broad like left-leaning broadly speaking
and it I mean left in the broadest
possible scope when I say this so so
yeah so these photographers when they
started to photography in the middle
class they were in a way also looking at
themselves so it's it's also going back
home and photography their acts of
leaving so a lot of photographs came out
of their own homes so somebody's dad
sipping tea in the morning or somebody
is relative folding clothes I mean as
simple as these acts were getting
documented so so if the first part was
kind of looking into the other side of
Calcutta for the photographer's and also
the middle-class viewers of those
photographs the second part was like a
really reflexive moment for this entire
practice of document in the city mm-hmm
okay and so minimally 4,000 photographs
for Calcutta where are these photographs
now and how did you orient yourself to
them what was the process like for you
right so all photographs negatives and
the prints that were made in the 70s
through the 90s
and the in the index cards that I
mentioned and they are absolutely
central so they would make this tiny
little cards put them on this index and
on the side they will actually have the
technical details so we actually have
the darkroom details of the kind of
chemical they used the kind of films
they use and the kind of camera so we
actually have the details like and of
course the footing of the photographer's
is still around so if you talk to the
photographer and then you take a look at
the index card it actually gives a sense
of what went behind the scene even
before this print called it the object
called photograph came into being in
this world so this entire thing is an
anchor Calcutta in in Chobani archive
which is in Ravi I'm at headway Road
that's pretty much in central Calcutta
okay so how many photographers did you
get a chance to speak with oh I was very
lucky so I mean they had 23
photographers I got a chance to talk to
I think like 15 or 16 Wow Wow how old
would they be now
oh they're like it varies really so from
a late 50s true mid 70s so that sort of
the age range right okay and did you
talk to them about it was what it was
like for them to participate in the
project oh yeah of course I mean when
they participated most of them were like
very young fresh graduates or in some
cases there was one person who was a
like college dropout and he was very
proud I mean he's still very firm and he
is like one of the finest photographers
of so these were they were like still
developing their skill and they were
really committed to the idea of social
justice so it wasn't like unnatural they
would go to church bonny and joined this
join this project so the first
generation of photographer who work for
the Shaheed Minar section of the project
I mean there was a advertisement that
went out asking photographers to join
second generation of photographers were
trained by the first generation of
photographers so when this project
started they also started a photography
training course along with it so the
second generation were more sort of like
in-house trained
but the first generation who like who
are initially joined from outside they
were also refining their skills so it's
a moment of for them it was moments of
discovery self-discovery as well as
discovery the medium and their personal
relationship with the medium and how to
go about it and most of them leg became
professionals later on and majority of
them went on field still photography
some went with moving pictures yeah yeah
moving picture photography so yeah so
you know in terms of the project I would
imagine multiple photos would have been
taken so I'm wondering what the how the
photos were ultimately chosen to be part
of the project who was tasked with that
uh-huh that's an excellent question
thank you Irene again we are talking
about a pre-digital world you know in a
resource care region where you can't
really afford to take a lot of
photographs you have to be very precise
so it's not like you have option of
taking ten shots of thing and then you
delete nine keep one or keep for delete
the rest 10 is 10 10 mins a lot I mean
so a case like celluloid cassettes of
films would have 36 gates and often
people would economize it so that you
they get at least like 39 it's possible
to do that but you have to be really
very precise okay and if film stocks
like that if cost is high does not like
so there weren't multiple shots in most
cases they were like at most like three
shots but in mostly it was like one two
okay that was the element so in that way
I mean for us often becomes really
difficult to choose which one we want to
keep for them it was like relatively
manageable in terms of number but in
terms of aesthetic choices and in terms
of what they really wanted to portray in
the photographs it wasn't as easy a
process was so there were discussions
okay so they would go out in the field
make photographs come back work in the
darkroom develop that and they would do
the darkroom themselves so it's not like
they'll send them to labs okay generator
Bonnie had its own very equipped lab
so yeah so they would work in the dark
room and then make contact sheets out of
them because that's that was we are
again a period where I remember those
days
oh thank you so much no no I'm just
distracting from what we are talking it
becomes very difficult to talk to
students and often I carry contact
sheets with me when I'm talking contact
because they have no clue what I'm
talking about
they have no any like a little loop that
you get out to make oh yeah so and
students like young so in first year
second years they often don't have a
clue that I'm really talking about an
object a physical thing that you can
hold in your hand and not a computer
screen anyway going back to the point so
they would develop me contact sheets and
they would have like they would all sit
together them meant the seniors and the
mentors if there are any from outside
sometimes there would be like volunteers
would come to work which each morning
and they would also participate and of
course father rubbish okay so father
aware it was a really monumental figure
in this entire institution and in the
project so so everybody's input was
essential and and there are really
people like Sasa 33 the in you're not
your I mean he was closely associated
with the the institution I mean some
time for the robe age would so show some
photographs to Ray and Ray would comment
on that so and there were like many
people like coming and going at some
point Orica the oppressor was there so
and they would have like discussion with
press of course mm-hmm
Katia verso is a very common sort of
Intel acuter both intellectually and
like in real life
mmm-hmm so yeah so they would discuss
that what is the objective that I went
out to field with and how how is it that
I'm contributing to a positive image of
the people that I'm photography so these
discussions would actually lead into the
kinds of photograph they want to keep or
they want to throw away let me tell you
they didn't throw away any so they have
the entire collection so yeah and but
for exhibition purposes they would
choose like handful but you also have to
think about the printing costs
the chemical cause I mean all these
things were also part of the story
behind how many photographs would
actually make it to save a gallery
exhibition or would actually be sold out
to people who'd come to buy prints okay
so I am curious if the people of
Calcutta themselves how many do you
think were able to see these photographs
yes that's a question about circulation
so initially all these photographs were
meant to be seen by the people who were
depicted in the photographs so community
exhibition was a major channel through
which these photographs were seen by the
people so so they would again take
photograph come back develop and go back
with the photograph okay so most people
went back some people didn't also I mean
they have their personal narrative of
why they didn't go back I mean yeah but
and but even without thinking about how
many people actually saw it I think it's
important to think from the perspective
of the institution the photographer's
that they really had an intention that
the widest possible like group would
actually come see their photograph so
they would reach out to the communities
rather than expecting communities to
come to them and see the photographs
apart from the community exhibitions a
lot of these photographs had travelled
through the Catholic circuits through
the church circuits okay
across the country and also out of the
country where did it go outside all in
Belgium so Belgium because of so far the
relation of like French Canadian origin
origin so volume Canada are some of the
places where this photographs travel
also there was one person you know who
was based in Montreal he's still based
in Montreal and he was in Calcutta for
the longest period of time and during
the initial year here years he was one
of the mentors so so this person was
there was actively engaged in the
project and so forth and he took his
photographs back when he moved back to
Montreal so so there are channels
through which the circuit in a weed in
Calcutta there were two major gallery
exhibition one in
in 1980s another in early 1990s so there
are eighties eighteen nineteen eighties
exhibition was on like the first project
I like the first section of the project
and the early 90s exhibition was on the
second part of the project so so there
are multiple channels through which
these photographs circulated and further
away as well as the photographer's
really wanted to reach out to different
segments different classes of people to
visually educate them about how to look
at a photograph right so ultimately do
you think the objective of the project
actually worked it really depends I mean
it's an interesting question and this is
a question I keep getting whenever I
talk about this project to others
because not a lot of people know that
this institution existed or this
photograph still exist out there and
people still are very attached to what
they made so the photographers are very
attached to the photographs they made
like two years back so there are twofold
objectives so one was to make a
difference in people lives the other
objective was to create a body of
photographs that would remain as for the
post era T as this moment in the cities
like along like three decades and cities
lives and so the first objective like
making a difference in people's life how
was it expected to happen like how can a
photograph be like really instrumental
in changing changing real-life situation
well so father Robert had a very good
answer for that so for him it's really
like restore by restoring dignity it's
giving people a positive sense of self
giving people hope that they are worthy
members of the society no matter what
like the hegemonic discourses in the
society make them believe they still
have equal share in in resources in
public life in public spaces and
asserting that right for them was seen
as a major positive state for the church
upon a collective I mean they didn't
formally call them our collective but
I call it lucky with a small C rather
than our uppercase C right so yeah so I
think that happened like I mean if you
ask me I would say yeah I mean I see the
point and it really contributed
positively in the question of human
development and of course they created
this huge archive of images I mean
that's like as a researcher I find it
pretty incredible valuable absolutely
but then if you go back to the
photographer's and if you ask them or if
you ask father waves they all have their
different answers
so for majority of the photographers
also it's interesting how over time
their answers changed so so there was
one photographer who said Oh photographs
can't make any change in anybody's life
so it was we were just kids we were
making photographs and we were very
happy about our aesthetic pursuits
mm-hmm another group of people the
majority of them would say like oh we
tried our best but it wasn't really
successful now this version is from 2006
I interviewed this same group in 2013
again and they said oh we were
definitely partially successful hmm you
asked father where he said oh we were
moderately successful and he's still
committed to the idea so so what is this
real change that we are talking about
does real change mean that I mean the
underprivileged would suddenly one fine
morning become a more economically
resourceful person or are we talking
about like change in their vision of
themselves so what is this hour exactly
so empowerment can happen at different
level right so when we say real we often
like associate real with material and I
as a researcher I see even if there's no
material gained through these
photographs there a lot of empowerment
that definitely happened right okay
final question you are here at Yale at
the Institute of sacred music doing some
work so tell us of what you're working
on well
the my project identity of sacred music
is was a was kind of a shoot off from
this paper and my larger book project so
the project that I Sam
it's called theology politics art
photographs from force emergency
Calcutta so and here in the project I'm
specifically looking at theology of
communication and that is something I
did not explore earlier in my research
so I was more concerned about the
photographer's the photograph they were
making so my focus was more towards this
objects and the images and the
materiality of photography image more
generally speaking but now I'm actually
looking into theology of communication
and because father rubbish wrote a lot
and not simply that I mean he was
clearly located within this like bigger
discussion mm-hmm over then what is now
global South and what the other point
was the third world so and there was
like a like a series of journals that
publish the theology of communication in
the third world
so I'm looking into those discursive
spaces and father relations location in
that kind of a global discussion and
then tried to think about the
photographs and this theology of
communication together so yeah so my
current project is pretty much kind of
began while I was working with this huge
body of more graphs well we will
certainly look forward to hearing more
from you thank you so much thank you so
much for being here it was really
fascinating oh thanks again for having
me for more information about professor
Roy surgery and her work please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale
you